So that about wraps up the course.
And just to do a recap of the things we've covered today, and
hopefully the things you've learned, we went over some of the considerations that you might need to make before you actually bring your Skeletal Mesh into the engine.
So things like bone orientations, your hierarchy, and how you might want to skin certain parts of your mesh.
Then we set up a few different control types that might be useful for mechanical rigging specifically.
As well as setting up a simple rig for our Mesh where we utilize some of the useful functions and nodes that are specifically aimed at mechanical rigging.
So thank you very much for your time and for following along with the course.
And don't forget we have plenty of other courses available to increase your control rig knowledge.
So if there's anything else you want to learn, please be sure to check those out.
But otherwise, best of luck with your mechanical rigging and thank you once again.
Thank you.